hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay the
biological basis of ethics Peter Singer
is going to discuss an important feature
of reciprocal altruism and he's going to
offer what he calls some social
biological explanations for how this
could have arisen why it would be
important and this has to do with the
the function of motivation or intention
if I'm behaving altruistically towards
another person that is I am doing things
that benefit them perhaps to the
detriment of my own interests or desires
you know putting off for example my own
desire to watch TV in order to help my
kid with their homework right things
along those lines
staying afterwards to talk with a
student even though you know I'd rather
go home and have dinner something along
those lines those are altruistic why do
we do those that's where intention or
motivation comes in and we can think of
all sorts of self-interested motives
that could be behind these seemingly
altruistic acts so why do I go the extra
mile for a student because I'm hoping
that student will give me a good review
on rate your professor calm or was some
similar site right sorry I'm trying to
get something out of it for myself why
do I do that for helping my kid with
their homework because I'd be so
embarrassed if my kid was revealed as
being a dummy who can't do basic
mathematics right and I'm invested
myself or I'm trying to get them ready
for the academic quiz bowl that I'm
pushing them towards so I can bask in
the glory of having a brilliant child or
whatever else that's gonna be trying to
keep the teachers off my kids back and
therefore off my back those are
self-interested motives and so Peter
Singer says that the practice of
reciprocal altruism that it should be
the source of many of our attitudes of
moral approval and disapproval including
ideas of fairness cheating gratitude and
retribution would be easier to accept if
it were not that this explanation seems
to put these attitudes and ideas on too
self-centered of a footing so he says
reciprocal altruism seems as if it's not
really altruism at all but a concealed
form of egoism a concealed form of
self-centered decision-making saying
what am I going to get out of it but I'm
not getting something out of it then I'm
not going to contribute now why would
reciprocal altruism look that way and
altruism per se not look that way
because reciprocal altruism says you do
good things for the person who also
benefits you right you don't you don't
benefit everybody indiscriminately that
would in fact be imprudent or foolish
and lead to you being shortchanged and
likewise reciprocal altruism would say
not only the ones who cheat or don't
reciprocate
can you feel certain negative feelings
towards them like indignation or
annoyance but you might actually even
take revenge on them you might punish
them for not reciprocating so that seems
rather self-interest that he says it
might really just be accurately
described
enlightened self-interest and this is
this is a true thing in many cases there
are a lot of people who are quite frank
and upfront about the fact that they're
only gonna do stuff for you because
they're getting something out of it so
he says one might be a fully
reciprocating partner in this practice
without having the slightest concern for
the welfare of the person one helps
concern for one's own interests plus the
knowledge that exchanges of assistance
are likely to be in the long-term
interests of both partners that's all
that's needed he says now consider an
example and see how this sits with you
so we've got again you know saving
somebody who is is having a very rough
time by drowning he says if I'm drowning
in a raging surf and a stranger plunges
in and rescue rescues me I shall be very
grateful and you know we show this in
all sorts of ways what if we find out he
says that the stranger recognised me as
being a person of means and then did a
mental calculation and said it's going
to be profitable to rescue this person
they will probably give me a nice reward
and somebody else is drowning further
down the beach and they're like well
that person's retirement portfolio is
not quite so good I'm gonna let them
drown well we would feel a sense of
something being wrong there right we
would say that that's the wrong
motivation to have and we wouldn't see
that person as being genuinely
altruistic and he says not it's not only
gratitude that diminishes when
self-interested motives are revealed
moral approval is always warmest for
acts which show either spontaneous
concern for the welfare of others or
else a conscientious desire to do what
is right proof that in action we have
praised that a self-interested motive
almost always leads us to withdraw or to
qualify to lessen our praise so singer
says well maybe we went wrong in how we
to find altruism so he says earlier in
this chapter here's the definition that
we accepted in terms of behavior
altruistic behavior is behavior which
benefits others at some cost to oneself
now notice that that has nothing to say
about intention or motivation why we're
doing it
it just says this is what we're doing so
he proposes that we should redefine it
in a different way
he says when people talk about altruism
they're normally thinking both of
behavior and of motivation so we should
redefine it as this and here's here's
his proposal behavior that benefits
others at some initial cost to oneself
and is motivated by the desire to
benefit others and we might actually
expand this and say benefit or to
protect or help out others you know it
doesn't necessarily have to be a
positive benefit it could be trying to
save them from something bad as well and
you know it's interesting if you think
about some of the actions that we take
or don't take very single day you know
some of them could be altruistic in
motivation for example we know from you
know statistical analyses and self
reporting that most people do not wash
their hands an adequate amount and many
people do not wash their hands at all
after visiting the restroom even if
they're working at a place where there's
a sign that says employees must wash
their hands before returning to work and
you said well you know why would why
shouldn't you why why would you wash
your hands what's protecting you right
you keep yourself from getting sick but
it's really about you know protecting
other people as well isn't it and you
know this is one of those tiny little
things that can contribute in so many
different ways that that often go unseen
to the benefit and welfare of others to
protecting them from transferring
diseases around right driving
if not the speed limit at least close to
the speed limit and being you know a
patient and unfocused driver rather than
you know looking at your phone or things
like that that's you know that could be
an altruistic act you said well I want
to do that just so I don't get in an
accident so the cops don't pull me over
you could also say well that's a good
thing to do because I didn't want to hit
other people or damage their cars or you
know create dangerous situations so
motivation would would matter then and
he says that let's let's think about how
this would would play itself out in
terms of an evolutionary schema or
explanation says Robert Trivers has
offered a sociobiological explanation
for our moral preference for altruistic
motivation why is it that we prefer
other people to be altruistic one reason
is very simple almost common sensical is
that people who are altruistically
motivated make more reliable partners in
whatever exchanges or other relations
that were involved in more reliable than
those motivated by self-interest how so
well you know you can say if they really
care at least some amount about how
other people are going to be affected
positively or negatively they will do
the right thing even when nobody's
watching
even when it's going to cut into their
profits a little bit more even when it
might be a little bit more
psychologically difficult so they can be
relied upon and he says after all one
day the calculations of self-interest
may turn out differently and he's got
the goes back to the beach example says
looking at the shabby clothes I have
left on the beach is self-interested
potential rescuer may decide that the
prospect of a sizable reward are dim so
we we want people who will rescue us or
do the other things that we want them to
do in similar circumstances regardless
of whether they're going to get
something out of it directly
so he says evolution would therefore
favor people who could distinguish
self-interested from altruistic
motivation and others then select only
the altruistic as beneficiaries other
gifts and services so he's talking about
how reciprocal altruism would function
well if evolution whether it's
understood and purely genetic terms are
also in terms of its interaction with
culture if if these processes would lead
to some things being favoured and other
things being disfavored namely
altruistic motivation then it's
important that we actually be able to
distinguish between those because
otherwise we can't reward those by being
altruistic towards them who are being
altruistic towards us and we lose the
reciprocity part because we would either
end up not being altruistic towards them
or we're being altruistic also to the
people who don't reciprocate and then
you know that's not going to be
particularly helpful and the person who
is doing the good thing has the right
motivation would would just receive the
same reward as everyone else so that's
part of the evolutionary explanation he
also thinks that there would be a
selection for people who actually have
altruistic motivations I think it's
important that we pause here for a
moment and think about how strong of a
claim Singer is making is he saying that
evolution would select for people who
are altruistic all the time or ninety
five percent of the time no he's not
saying that he's saying that these are
tendencies
even people who are altruistic a good
portion of the time at least in my
experience aren't generally so all of
the time it's a matter of a continuum
and so what would be favored here would
being would be the person who is more
reciprocally altruistic and what would
be disfavored would be the person who's
less so
in their motivation if people can tell
what the motivations are and they may be
able to tell what the motivations are
because the person who's not actually
altruistic is dumb enough to tell them
and brag about it or it might be that
they have a better way of seeing through
the ruses of social life so this this
sort of selection would be going on and
he says that if there are advantages in
being a partner in a reciprocal exchange
and if one is more likely to be selected
as a partner if one has genuine concern
for others there is an evolutionary
advantage in having a genuine concern
for others assuming of course that we
can see through a pretense of altruism
by those who are really self-interested
and evolutionary theory then would also
predict one further thing that we would
get better at developing pretense but at
the same time the performance of the
pretenders would probably improve so
there'd be sort of a dialectic or
dynamic in there of moral hypocrisy and
being able to read between the lines you
could say being able to tell whether
somebody is genuinely altruistic or not
and there I think that we you know we
probably get much more into the social
than the biological but that's that's a
little bit of a speculation there what
are the implications in Peter singers
view for the sociobiological perspective
that he is laying out here in the paper
he says this conclusion is highly
significant because it cuts across the
tendency of sociobiological reasoning to
behave to explain behavior in terms of
self-interest or the interests of one's
kin so this lead to a better more robust
more complicated account on a
sociobiological basis
he says properly understood sociobiology
does not imply that behavior is actually
motivated by the desire to further one's
own interests or those of one's kin
sociobiology actually says nothing about
motivation because it remains
level of the objective consequences of
types of behavior but he says it is a
common assumption sociobiology implies
that were motivated by self-interest not
genuine altruism this assumption gains
credibility from some of the things that
socio biologists write and then singer
says we can see now that social
sociobiology itself can explain the
existence of genuinely altruistic
motivation not just concealed
self-interest but genuinely altruistic
motivation that would have developed in
our you know development our ancestry
our whatever you want to call it the
mishmash of prehistory behind us of all
those generations of human beings so
this is kind of an interesting point to
develop with respect to associate
biology but we might look at it in a
broader sense and say that what Singer
is saying here has implications for
accounts of ethics generally that it's
really important that we be able to find
some way of incorporating motives why
because that is how people actually do
judge whether people are altruistic or
not they focus on why a person is
engaging in the action
you